with bird box now on wide release many
things about the film are finally coming
to light through the numerous press to
us that the cast are doing throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the movie's original ending and what is
revealed there will of course be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the movies final
ending then I highly suggest that you
turn off now but for everyone else and
definition and welcome to the channel
where I roon it so you don't have to in
bird boxes final cut we see Sandra
Bullock make it up River and arrive at
Janet's school for the blind with their
two children she finally names them and
seems happy after forming a meaningful
attachment with them which she'd been
unable to do previously however the film
originally had a much darker finale when
Malory arrived at the sanctuary she
discovers that the residents there had
actually forcefully blinded themselves
this completely removed any chance of
them ever witnessing the monsters all
being forced to look upon them by any of
the people that were deemed crazy it's a
lot less hopeful than the final ending
and boy and girl probably would have had
to blind themselves to which is pretty
twisted anyway in this alternative
ending we also finally got a glimpse at
the monsters and whilst there are no
images of them currently star Sandra
Bullock revealed what they look like in
an interview with Bloody Disgusting she
stated that the monsters were green men
with a horrific baby face
they were snake-like and I was like I
don't want to see it when it first
happens just bring it into the room
we'll shoot the scene a turn and he's
like this it's making me laugh it was
just a long fat baby obviously you can
see why the creative team decided to
remove any glimpse of the monster
especially if it was just a long fat
baby and personally I kind of think the
film works better without showing them
of course I'd love to hear your thoughts
on which ending you prefer and if you
still would have liked to have seen the
monsters even if they did look like
awful the doc so make sure you leave
them in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and check out my breakdown and
inau
of the film's final ending which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are heavy into horror so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]